♪ ♪
>> WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN THE
FORCED RESIGNATION OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE AFTER
THE ELECTION.
IT IS CLEAR, THEREFORE, THAT
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE TO
PROTECT MR. MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION.
>> THIS IS ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH ASSERTING A COMMON SENSE
CHECKS AND BALANCES ON
PRESIDENTIAL OVERREACH.
>> THIS IS A SOLUTION IN SEARCH
OF A PROBLEM.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO
FIRE ROBERT MUELLER.
>> Bret: THREE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TAKING TO THE FLOOR TO TRY TO
FORCE A VOTE ON THE BILL TO
PROTECT SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER.
THIS HAPPENED BEFORE NEWS BROKE
OF A NEW YORK POST ARTICLE
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISQ
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISO
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISE
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT IS,
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISA
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISK
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISD
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISA
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISO
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT IST
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISP
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISR
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISO
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISI
PIECE IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT ISG
PAUL MANAFORT, HIS FORMER
CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN.
"IT WAS NEVER DISCUSSED BUT I
WOULDN'T TAKE IT OFF THE TABLE.
WHY WOULD I TAKE IT OFF THE
TABLE?"
THAT PROMPTED A LOT OF RESPONSE
ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> THAT IS PAR FOR THE COURSE, I
GUESS, TO HOLD THAT AND DANGLE
IT OUT THERE.
>> THE REAL DANGER THERE IS THE
PARDON, WHICH IS TRUMP'S
INTEREST, AND WOULD BE SOLID
EVIDENCE OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY
CONVERSATIONS INVOLVING A PARDON
AT ALL.
>> Bret: IT IS A FOUR CAR
ALARM FIRE ON CAPITOL HILL
TODAY.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL,
CHARLES HURT, AMY WALTER, AND
HUGO GURDON, EDITORIAL DIRECTOR
FOR THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
AMY, THOUGHTS?
>> THAT IS NOT THE ONLY FOUR
ALARM FIRE GOING ON, THE
SAUDI ARABIA QUESTION, WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO DO IN THE WAR ON
YEMEN, WE CONTINUE TO GET
SUPPORT FOR SAUDI ARABIA, AND OF
COURSE MUELLER, AND THEN YOU
HAVE JUDGES.
ALL OF THOSE TRYING TO GET
SQUEEZED INTO THE NEXT WEEK,
WEEK AND A HALF.
THESE THINGS WOULD LIKE TO GET
ON.
WE ALSO HAVE A LAME DUCK SESSION
WHERE WE NEED TO PASS THE
NUMBERS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
BILLS.
THIS SEEMS TO BE ONE OF THE MANY
THINGS THAT CONGRESS IS
JUGGLING.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE WAS
GOING TO BE AN ANSWER TO WHETHER
OR NOT WE WILL GET A MUELLER
PROBE RIGHT NOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE FLAKE IS OUT THERE
A LITTLE BIT ON HIS OWN IN TERMS
OF BEING THE ONE REPUBLICAN THAT
COULD MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
TO ME, THE QUESTION IS --
>> Bret: AND CORKER IS THERE.
>> THAT IS TRUE, BUT FLAKE IS
SAYING I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
ANY JUDICIAL NOMINEES THAT COME
THROUGH UNLESS I GET THIS VOTE,
AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT HAS
ENOUGH LEVERAGE TO GET THAT VOTE
TO THE FLOOR, ON TOP OF THE
OTHER VOTES REBUKING THE
PRESIDENT, ONE OF WHICH HAPPENED
TODAY ON SAUDI ARABIA.
HOW MANY OF THOSE CAN MITCH
McCONNELL CONTINUE TO HOLD UP?
>> Bret: >> Bret: HUGO.
>> THE PRESIDENT DOES HAVE A WAY
OF DANGLING THINGS, OR ANOTHER
WAY OF LOOKING AT IT IS
EXPRESSING THINGS IN A WAY WHICH
POKED THE HORNETS NEST.
BY JUST SUGGESTING HE IS NOT
GOING TO TAKE IT OFF THE TABLE,
IT SUGGESTS TO THE DEMOCRATS WHO
HAVE BEEN SAYING HE WANTS TO
PARDON MAN FOR         PAUL MANF
PARDON MAN FOR         PAUL MANR
PARDON MAN FOR         PAUL MANT
PARDON MAN FOR         PAUL MANA
IS WHAT HE IS GOING TO DO.
BUT IT WORKS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
FAVOR, BECAUSE EVEN IF THE
PRESIDENT HAS NO INTENTION OF
DOING THIS AND HAS THE MAJORITY
LEADER IN THE SENATE, MITCH
McCONNELL SAYING THAT THIS IS
A SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM, IT ALLOWS THEM TO KEEP
STOKING THE IDEA THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO TRY AND DO
THIS.
I THINK THEY WOULD HAVE A TOUGH
TIME PROVING OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE IF THE PRESIDENT
EXERCISES HIS CONSTITUTIONAL
POWER AND ACTUALLY DOES THE
PARDON.
>> Bret: THERE ARE PEOPLE UP
THERE TODAY THAT ARE SAYING JUST
BY SAYING WHAT HE SAID, IT'S
ALREADY OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THE SNOWBALL JUST GOES DOWNHILL
VERY QUICKLY HERE.
>> WELCOME TO THE NEXT TWO YEARS
OF WASHINGTON, AND IN PARTICULAR
CONGRESS.
THE GOOD NEWS FOR THE PRESIDENT
IS THAT BECAUSE OF THE ELECTION,
THE G.O.P., THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IS GOING TO BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TRUMPER.
PEOPLE LIKE JEFF FLAKE AND BOB
CORKER WON'T BE THERE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
IT WILL MOSTLY BE DEMOCRATS THAT
ARE PLAYING THESE GAMES.
IN TERMS OF THE ISSUE OF
PARDONING, ONCE AGAIN, IT'S A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE TRUMP
SAYING SOMETHING -- IT'S THAT HE
DANGLES SOMETHING.
IT'S THAT HE ACTUALLY ENUNCIATES
IT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THIS IS THE
SORT OF THING THAT PARDONS HAVE
BEEN USED FOR FOREVER, AND WE
CAN SAY WHATEVER WE WANT ABOUT
PAUL MANAFORT, AND IT'S GREAT
THAT HE HAS BEEN FOUND GUILTY OF
CRIMES THAT HE COMMITTED, BUT OF
COURSE HE COMMITTED THEM A LONG
TIME AGO AND THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHY FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
DIDN'T GO AFTER IT BACK THEN,
THAT REMAINS TO BE ANSWERED.
BUT THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THAT AND WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING
IS THE FACT THAT HE GOT INVOLVED
IN POLITICS AND SPECIFICALLY --
THAT BY DEFINITION IS A
POLITICAL PROSECUTION.
>> Bret: IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RESTATE THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW.
I SAY THAT ALL THE TIME.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT A LOT OF
STORIES HAVE REALLY FALLEN APART
AND GOTTEN A LOT OF TRACTION.
THERE WAS A REPORT YESTERDAY
THAT PAUL MANAFORT MET WITH
ASSANGE.
THIS IS THE WASHINGTON TIMES.
PAUL MANAFORT'S PASSPORT DON'T
SHOW THAT HE ENTERED LONDON WHEN
THEY SAID HE MET SECRETLY WITH
WIKILEAKS JULIAN ASSANGE.
THEY SAY HE MET WITH HIM IN
2013, 2016.
A REVIEW OF HIS TWO PASSPORT
SAID HE ENTERED THE AIRPORT
SINCE 2008 ON TWO OCCASIONS.
2012 AND ANOTHER TIME WITH A
CUSTOMS STAMP, THE YEAR IS
BLURRED.
IT APPEARS TO SAY 2010 OR 2016.
THE POINT IS, THAT ATTEND COURT
RECORD FROM HIS TRIALS IN A KIND
OF FALLS APART.
IT TOOK UP A LOT OF AIRWAVES
YESTERDAY.
>> YEAH, IT WAS NOTABLE THAT NO
OTHER NEWS ORGANIZATION WAS
ABLE -- THEY SAID WE CAN'T
CONFIRM THIS.
>> AND THEY WALKED IT BACK.
>> AND "THE GUARDIAN" INTROS
SAID, "THE GUARDIAN HAS BEEN
TOLD."
THEY WERE NOT EVEN STANDING BY
THEIR OWN STORY.
THEY SAID, WE HAVE BEEN TOLD IS.
>> Bret: MY POINT IS, IN THE
VACUUM OF INFORMATION --
>> EXACTLY.
WHY WOULD -- IF THE PROSECUTION
IS ALL POLITICAL -- MUELLER BE
CUTTING A DEAL WITH PAUL
MANAFORT IF HE DIDN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO BE GIVEN HIM?
THIS WOULD BE OVER.
SO THERE IS CLEARLY MORE THAT
THEY WANTED TO GET FROM HIM
THAT, IT'S NOT OVER.
>> Bret: IT'S NOT OVER.
THEY'VE GOT SOMETHING.
>> THE IDEA THAT THEY COULD JUST
PROSECUTE HIM AND LET IT BE
DONE --
>> Bret: OR THEY THINK THEY
HAVE SOMETHING.
CORSI, WHO IS ALSO FACING A
CHARGE OF LYING, HE WAS ON OUR
CHANNEL LAST NIGHT.
>> I NEVER MET JULIAN ASSANGE, I
NEVER HAVE SPOKEN WITH HIM, I
NEVER EMAILED HIM, I HAVE HAD NO
CONTACT WITH JULIE MASSAGE
WHATSOEVER.
I HAVE BEEN A LOYAL AMERICAN.
I HAVE NO CONTACTS WITH RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE, I HAVE NO BUSINESS
INTEREST IN RUSSIA, I HAVE NO
INTEREST IN RUSSIA, I HAVE NEVER
BEEN TO RUSSIA.
>> Bret: THESE DENIALS ARE
PRETTY STRAIGHT.
WHO IS TELLING THE TRUTH, WHO IS
NO?
WE KNOW WHAT MUELLER HAS, HE HAS
A LOT OF INVESTIGATIVE MONTHS
BEHIND HIM, BUT IT SEEMS TO BE
COMING TO A HEAD HERE.
>> IT CERTAINLY DOES.
THESE ARE AS CATEGORICAL DENIALS
AS ONE COULD POSSIBLY GET.
THE FALLING TO PIECES OF THE
DEAL THAT PAUL MANAFORT HAD WITH
THE PROSECUTOR IS ANOTHER SIGN
THAT THIS HAS COME TO -- I THINK
THAT MANAFORT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
HE IS LOOKING FOR A PARDON AND I
HE IS LOOKING FOR A PARDON AND T
DOES RAISE QUESTIONS OF WHY THE
PRESIDENT WOULD WANT TO GIVE HIM